[Music]
got into the one day my second you
better believe he can
[ __ ] bloody slaughter Kovac
you look at this posture and you have
three of the five players were in the
conversation for the best player in the
world this is a dark round Maoist way
Jose aw good flag back
don't get a couple more of this one i
milk you everything to see us enter this
team face plan will be my last home
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Guardian was once known as one of the
greatest csgo players in the world but
these days people are calling him washed
Unreal from Stan just one more leftist
cardi with 4hp disaster strikes wants to
get but navi god it pulls out a pistol
but it's all over
1640s that makes it happen and EG
they've taken down navi in two maps but
before all that Guardian was a Slovakian
oper extraordinaire he got his start in
1.6 then worked his way up through some
lower ranked teams and csgo before
eventually becoming a force to be
reckoned with free bugs way exists
follow suit as now only Guardian stands
1v3
won't be one he's running the club to
the absolute by the time he joined Navi
in 2013 you just couldn't talk about the
best players in the world without
mentioning Guardians name quickly
falling apart here for Navi getting a
bit scary but that Guardian that's I'm
gonna say about that takes out the kill
on a large
Guardian was a master of the OP CS goes
a conic sniper rifle he was deadly
precise and accurate and when he was on
Navi Zeus trained him in a slightly
different style than most offers were
using at the time
see while most offers were like Kenny s
in-your-face and explosive Guardian was
trained to hold angles play precise and
slow and it worked
he's reining in he lines them up and
gets the first shot through looking for
a bit more that's the bomb down on us
hacker Guardian he has no mercy at all
he gets that flick oh my god takes down
TD and now it's on to verse 3 they got 5
seconds 4 seconds they can't get the
bomb down here it goes Guardian is
knocking tyloo out with an ace at the
end and while Navi wasn't always a
favorite at every major they attended
everyone knew at the back of their minds
that anything with Guardian on it always
had a shot and the title because she
chose us at the beginning of of my
entire beginning of Sisko
but it was not about he's always being
liked about the world Guardians first
shot at major victory came in 2015 at
cluj-napoca as the backbone of na vi's
line up over the last couple of years
Guardian went into the tournament
swinging his opportunities Guardian
coming in but Navi now moving towards
the B bomb site JDM has defended this
very well so far but he's gonna get
taken down by Guardian this time tarik
that's what he can but it's only gonna
be one Frank Bartlett vs. 3 he'll get
traded as well Guardian bee sting
everyone because now they want to walk
out meat using this actually quite
clever but Guardian he spots it coming
with the AWP and again that rotation
point that's all they have to work with
right now from ni pcs will take down
exist flame me with another it's gonna
be this round it's gotta be all over
it's down to Freiburg 1 vs. 5 and n IP
well they may surprise us but they will
not make you feel
there's final it's Navi on their first
appearance against envyus
but in the grand finals enemy has proved
too much for Navi to handle at least
twenty Donis the pistols champion got
Ian goes down played me Sue's neck
Edward gonna be a little axe man age
meeting up with a triple kill and then
play DS news to our Guardian rather has
been spotted Edward is holding the line
at b ches there with the heads on
technique a is doing work he's got three
kills make that four Stingo handedly
doing the table Navi now it's all on
Zeus he walks in there Kenny and it's
going to be the run be one clutch
situation hit n PK pull up the ACE and
keep it be on top or Zeus come through
as the heroes know it's not meant to be
every game with a shot five kills on a
second head show there flamie gonna be
going here she man there
[Applause]
[Music]
as a penny and a water victory now being
looked at moralized Guardian just
couldn't do it as disappointing as that
loss was it was only one major he still
had his whole career ahead of him and he
got his next chance just a few months
later at the MLG Columbus major his
Cajun is well gonna fall and I dare say
it's over now the air in the grand final
the second straight time this time
around though Garden was playing with a
huge disadvantage he had an injury that
was forcing him to play on an extremely
high sensitivity to offset its effects
it was so bad that he even considered
surgery which meant that winning this
major wasn't gonna be easy
Gardens injury resulted in a less than
stellar performance it was probably his
worst since joining Navi but he felt
that if he tried hard enough he can
still help his team lift that trophy so
you go if they feel that you aren't
playing very well why I have reasons I
had the hand injury and I it's hard to
come back for me but for sure I will do
my best in the finals but yeah if I have
reasons to play like I'm playing but
hopefully I will be good but history
repeated itself for Guardian in the
grand finals luminosity took the first
map and then in the second now be
crumbled and now it is a 102 taco look
at the see if he could close it out here
and win it for the Brazilians it's gonna
be a big turnaround there hits that shot
on soups amounts of one-on-one Guardian
versus taco it may just be destined to
fade
winning a major championship the loss
affected Guardian deeply he felt like he
couldn't perform for his team when they
needed him the most it was second place
sure but second place wasn't good enough
if I would talk about the pressure I
feel it's not because of the titles of
being the best sniper or something but
because my team is relying on me a lot
and when I fail it feels so bad
and Guardi didn't realize it but his
time was running out
Navi it was about to add simple which
was gonna lead to a huge overhaul of the
roster Guardians major title was getting
further and further away but Guardians
first tournament with the new Navi
looked like the start of something great
season in the open nearly gets caught
toward the sandwiches past head he will
go down to that snail
the champion so one New York
[Applause]
right I've been with you for a long time
we've known each other for over a dozen
years I know how much this means to you
did you put it in words for your fans
thank God and then everything fell apart
as personalities clashed and milling
performances plagued the roster Guardian
realized that his time on the team he'd
carried so often was coming to an end
Guardian eventually chose to leave Navi
and still searching for that major win
he joined faze clan you look at this
roster and you have three of the five
players were in the conversation for the
best player in the world fans were
expecting great things from fails and
despite all the challenges of adapting
to a new team Guardian was - I mean it's
always exciting to play land even but
especially in a new team it's completely
different different language now we are
so now I'm speaking English and Russian
so it's completely new and I mean these
are first-year and we are still like
bonding together so we have bond as
estimated it will come time a time
spending time in with each other but it
was awesome impact Guardian was so happy
on phase that he said that it was gonna
be the team he retired on he was
planning for the future he still
believed he was gonna win that major and
go out on top so I think faze clan will
be my last home as a active player and
that's why I mean I play a lot of CS
that's why I do everything to teach you
as much as we can as a team until I
announce my retirement so I will give
everything to CS and to this team until
I quit CS but the true test came at the
2018 Boston major it was Guardians
chance to prove to his former teammates
in Navi that he was better off without
them to prove that he deserved a legacy
as one of the gods of CSKA it was
Guardians time to shine and simple hold
on to whatever they carried us great
read from Zeus to hold off
because he knew see cheap enough so the
vent was nest lifeless nests likely I
should say what a shelf of Guardian
words out of my mouth as he nails it
through the box he is tagged up smoke on
the ball immediately he's got the kid
doesn't like to hold on to the final egg
Guardian is an absolute dog heading into
the grand finals
he's were the favorites against cloud 9
Guardians major victory was so quotes
face took the first map and Guardian was
playing out of his mind
oh well that is a shot in the hospital
charge he even set a record for the most
op kills in a single map 25 kill Oh God
- they still want to go look how they
must fall to both the peaks come in but
Guardian will not stop one more to go
and Guardian gets them all Guardian
wanted the major Guardian wanted his
major but it wasn't enough
Guardian waits patiently as pal my
scepter push up
[Applause]
there are two sides to every story
cloud nines run at the Boston major has
gone down it was one of the greatest
underdog stories in the history of CS
but for Guardian that was the loss that
broke him he gave it his all just to see
his dream of winning a major go down the
drain for the third time his major dream
was all but dead Guardian kept playing
for phase but the results were getting
worse and worse once they find out where
he is surely it's impossible a mac-10
for neo versus three can you get around
the corner he can't do it renegades take
it they survived and they eliminate
faith clan from the major so many dreams
have been crushed here for Phase a
disastrous run at the Berlin major in
2019 was the last straw the team decided
that it was time for Guardian to go hang
him removed was really hard but it was
something the team needed I think I
think we needed one change wouldn't be
enough I think at this moment we kept
changing won't play we won't play all
the time we never felt like we had a new
roster so a two changes was needed and
firstly this time it was it was thought
it has to go Guardian received several
offers but ultimately he decided to go
with the devil he knew Guardian rejoined
Navi unfortunately it wasn't quite the
homecoming Guardian was hoping for
there's nothing left now no chance of
one bus is full and snappy goes down and
at the start of 2020 after months of
mixed performances Navi decided to bench
Guardian this time it wasn't his choice
recently Guardian was loaned out to
Dignitas while one of their players
sorts out some visa issues but dig
aren't exactly major contenders they're
not the kind of team that Guardian was
searching his whole career for gem right
in front here gonna be picking up the
ball and try and put it down in me to
the infinite he's hiding on the other
side it should be a free kill
and he will go down to the infinite
leaving guardian in a one-on-one with
Waddell who's just waiting for it and
that's gonna be it 16 - Street and at
this point it seems like Guardian will
go down in history as one of the
greatest players to have never won a
major
if Guardian does end up retiring from
professional CS it'll be a new beginning
for him it's not that the dream is dead
it's just that some things are never
meant to be despite our best efforts but
no matter how Guardians see s journey
ends one thing is for certain it was a
hell for ride thanks for watching if you
want more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you will
find anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]